hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trainsenses.com so yesterday i did a
video about amc and today as many of you
are asking me in the comments i'm gonna
do a video only on gme so let's get into
it
[Music]
all right so uh let's start with the
chat i'm gonna do the same as i did
yesterday for mc first we're gonna
analyze only the technicals then we're
gonna go to the option market and try to
find information that is relevant to
what can happen on the price so
as usual we take a step back
and we try to see what is happening here
so bam we had clearly here
a nice one two three four five okay but
this is one two three this is only a
third wave i think we're on a big false
wave abcde and we are waiting to break
uh to break out on the upside probably
above 260 280 to uh make a fifth wave so
for now we are still in this corrective
uh force wave i have to say that this
counting has been updated at some point
and we gonna follow the press action so
for now what we can say is that we are
in the bullish development so let's zoom
in
we are clearly in a bullish development
here so what the question we're having
is is this false wave that i just showed
you on a bigger time frame complete here
and this is the beginning of the fifth
or are we still in the force question
for now as long as we are below the this
trend line 280 there is still a
possibility that this is a false wave
and that after reaching that level we're
gonna correct more it's possible another
scenario is that this false wave
corrective pattern is complete with the
e wave coming here a b c d e triangle
that usually often uh happen in the in
force waves and that this is already the
beginning of a fixed wave that is going
to look like this okay
something like that
so we don't have enough information here
to know and answer this question with a
high probability so what we can do is to
see what is happening on the shorter
term so on the shorter term we are
looking to get a hint about if
if the trend is
up or down we need to find where the
five waves uh pattern is happening so
basically whenever you have five waves
in a direction can be up or down it
means that it's very likely to be the
trend so for now we have one two three
very very obvious then here four
i mean let's zoom in here guys i don't
really like what happened here let's be
honest because i'm going to show you
what this is this is
uh a bearish divergence all right so we
have one two three four and here it's a
fifth guys okay we did a new high
so
is the fifth wave complete and then
we're gonna correct maybe so maybe then
then this would be a first wave we could
also have something like this like you
know
one two three four five it's possible as
well so up up
okay
this is uh something that we need to
keep in mind it's possible that this
first wave won't go that high okay
and we first gonna have a correction
before going higher i mean from there
it's very hard to really say if this
wave is complete or not so what we can
use uh like i said guys on my discord is
we can use trend lines here and we can
see that
what happened here is not really nice
okay we had here the breakout on friday
and we moved lower but does it mean that
there is no alternative for fifth wave
to come no and i would say same as for
amc as long as we are above this uh
trend line here this could be still a
false wave it's not a nice false wave
let's be honest because it shouldn't
make a new high here but it still can be
a force wave so to know if this force
wave is natural or not let's measure it
okay usually force waves they like to go
to the uh 38.2 percent of wave three ah
haha surprise where are we 38.2 percent
once again guys i don't invent this
numbers for those who are watching my
video for some time you know where i get
it from but for the new viewers
you need to have a look at that page 79
9 in the edit wave book
four slaves they like to go to the 38.2
percent uh retracement of wave three so
this is what i'm using here so for now
there is nothing unusual but below that
okay we should start to break below 195
180 this doesn't look like a false wave
anymore this looks like a correction
starting so this is the levels we are
gonna watch to know what might happen on
the price action and once again
to turn uh very bullish on my side this
is once again only my tools and it's not
perfect but it's definitely helping i
need to see the price action trading
above this trend line here guys okay
i'm so right now the level is
okay let's get going lower 275 roughly
okay so i want to see the price action
above that level uh and doing something
like this and this is going to be a bang
level uh here
we we wait it might squeeze as well so
basically this is uh what i'm seeing
from technical analysis now let's have a
look at the option market uh because
it's full of information so jimmy
okay
we refresh
okay
we load
nice okay so what i'm looking at five
percent of synthetic short at the money
so right now but okay okay so this is
the option market distribution so you
can see we have a massive strike at 950
with a lot of open interest the biggest
one just like we have for amc so this is
creating this gamma okay so we can see
that uh from now 202
to when all the options are in the money
we go from five percent of synthetic
short to 25 so 20 increase which means
that market makers need to buy on the
upside that's what we call the gamma
okay we can see that it's coming from
all the upside calls
mostly from the 915.
so this is the reason why we have this
bullish momentum on the upside and once
again i only see amc and gme having this
kind of distributions when i have a look
at okay you want to quickly have a look
at sprt but basically you don't have
that many strikes
okay so in terms of number it's
absolutely insane we are here close to
100 percent
okay 106
but where is it coming from
we have some very upside okay but you
have more at the 30 so even sprt but
it's a completely different game the
market cap is smaller i mean i'm still
trying to understand exactly how those
screws are working i mean let's see
what i'm seeing is that like i don't
understand how this can really not
squeeze but the price action is bearish
right now so like i'm saying on my
discord guys now i would be careful on
those two but let's see i think we're
gonna have some surprises later uh let's
go back to jamie
okay i just wanted to show you that guys
for you to see uh how the other squeeze
plays are looking and jimmy and amc are
still the ones that are the most
impressive okay
and very interesting
information i want to show you is where
is it coming from guys
bam we open
and we try to look for the greens
so here september september september
okay which one is this
680 september so where is the 950 strike
here okay and this one is coming from
okay
same thing same as amc guys so gen 22 is
the maturity you have the most options
on the 950 strike basically it's not
open on september and october but still
in terms of total uh option open
interest we have
the same amount of options on gen 22 as
we do on sep 21
so this means that once again this
phenomenon is gonna last so i'm still
gonna be making videos for sure in three
months maybe even in six months or one
year on these two stocks because it's
still gonna move and there's still gonna
be interesting things to say as we have
this option uh distribution that is
gonna put pressure on market makers for
at least three months even six months
then 22. so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys